et là
C'est là
[Musique]
et là
C'est là
et aujourd'hui maintenant le président de la république
il faut comprendre que les gens sont
marquer dans les moments les plus difficiles de
ton histoire des milliers de morts
familles endeuillées chômage un
fantôme de la faim hantant les maisons des
les habitants des favelas et à quoi s'attendre
alors président de la république
comme ça, les pressions et l'espoir de
sobriété solidaire envers
qu'est-ce que la régularisation foncière du
notre région, c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
et comment attendre au-delà de l'informatique
la manifestation ici aujourd'hui est pour le
les gens se souviennent d'avoir couvert les autorités
position ferme et faisant autorité qui
les autorités se comportent comme des enfants
malheureusement, nous voulons que ceux-ci aient
comme l'autorité pour que ces vies
les plus pauvres n'ont plus besoin d'être creusés
des vies peuvent être préservées et
C'est là
et là
[Musique]
g1